NUMBERS OF UNSUSPECTING
PATIENTS THEN THEY USE THAT
INFORMATION TO BILL FOR
LUCRATIVE BUT UNNEEDED GENETIC
TESTS THAT CAN COST THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
AN AMERICAN VETERAN, A MARINE
NOW ENGAGED IN ANOTHER KIND OF
FIGHT FOR THE FREEDOM OF NORTH
KOREA IS IN LEGAL JEOPARDY
TONIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, SOME WHO KNOW WHAT
HE IS FACING WORRY HIS LIFE MAY
ALSO BE IN DANGER.
SENIOR CORRESPONDENT ERIC SHAWN
HAS DETAILS.
>> IS HE A U.S. MARINE WHO COULD
BE EXECUTED BY KIM JONG UN SAY
HIS SUPPORTERS.
IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO TRY AND EXTRADITE
HIM.
CHRISTOPHER ON WHO SERVED IN
IRAQ FACES CHARGES IN SPAIN THAT
HE BROKE INTO THE NORTH KOREAN
EMBASSY IN MADRID TWO YEARS AGO
AND SPANISH AUTHORITIES WANT HIM
BACK.
>> THEY HAVE TOLD ME THAT THAT
DANGER IS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THAT DANGER
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASES IF I
LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
AND THE SAME DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT'S TOLD ME THAT IF I
LEAVE THE COUNTRY, THAT I COULD
BE ASSASSINATED IS THE SAME
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT'S
TRYING TO EXTRADITE ME.
SO, YES, I MEAN, THE FEAR IS
THERE.
>> CHRIS, SAYS HE WAS INVITED IN
AS PART OF A PLAN BY ANTI-REGIME
ACTIVIST GROUP FREE NORTH KOREA
TO HELP KIM JONG UN'S AMBASSADOR
TO SPAIN DEFECT.
BUT THE DIP CHANGED HIS MIND.
>> THEY MAY BE NORTH KOREA BUT
THEY ARE PARENTS AND THEY LOVE
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEY HAVE
BEEN FED LIES THEIR ENTIRE LIFE
AND THEY COME TO A WESTERN
COUNTRY AND THEY REALIZE THAT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
TOLD ARE LIES.
>> AT COURT TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT, THE PARENTS OF THE
CO-WARMBIER THE 22-YEAR-OLD
COLLEGE STUDENT TORTURED AND
SENT HOME TO DIE BY KIM REGIME
IN 2017.
IN AN EMARINE PLEA THAT BROUGHT
SPECTATORS TO TEARS MRS. WHAM
BEER TOLD THE COURT, QUOTE NO
ONE EVER STANDS UP TO NORTH
KOREA I AM STANDING UP NORTH
KOREA.
I AM STANDING UP FOR CHRIS AHN A
GOOD MAN.
>> THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IS TRYING
TO EXTRADITE ME.
IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO,
QUITE FRANKLY.
BUT I ALSO HAVE TRUST IN THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT.
I HAVE TRUST IN THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM.
AND, QUITE FRANKLY, I HAVE TRUST
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> WELL, THE U.S. MAGISTRATE
GENE ROSEN BOOTH IS EXPECTED TO
ISSUE A DECISION O